the fire
there will be no solace in this journey
no pee
yes until my
who is her prayer
for the sores laughs surrendered
there's no comment
Bosh's labor for me
in the case
I am cursed to
I don't even know how I found myself
here I don't even know
to find my way
Oh
we go
your fees
Oh
one of the most important things I think
with soul songs is to make sure that
they're available for as many people as
possible for whatever price you value it
at so you guys can go to band camp and
you can pay whatever you want for a copy
of this song be at five cents or 10
pounds of five dollars whatever and
maybe only one percent of you guys will
do that and that's fine because that is
still a crazy amount of support if you
think about it so thank you
I still remember vividly what happened
when the first soul song came out and I
got to witness firsthand just what if
crazy effect you guys can have and how
supportive you can be to a band I was so
proud of what we did then and I'm
continually amazed and I hope that you
give this band some love for creating
something awesome even if it's just as
small as a like on Facebook or something
like that I really appreciate it
this was one of those projects that
enthralls you from start to finish and
I'm actually pretty happy with how it
turned out which is something I don't
say too often so I was honored to be a
part of it I was trying to tell a story
in this video I don't know how many
people caught on to that or how obvious
it was but I wrote a description of it
down below if you want to understand why
I showed the gameplay in that order and
the type of story I was trying to tell
and thinking maybe I'll do a narrated
explanation of the story in this video
as well maybe as a bonus video for
patrons or something because the story
of Anne Marie and Horace is such a
gorgeous tale and I think this has been
one of the best ways I could have told
it so thank you for watching I've talked
too long please support the artist and
I'll see you guys in the next one bye
bye
you